regenerative medicine captures the
body's ability to heal itself and
accelerates that to a clinically
relevant time scale my name is Alan
Russell and I direct the McGowan
Institute for regenerative medicine at
the University of Pittsburgh and UPMC
within our body we have many natural
mechanisms which allow us to heal but
they just take place rather slowly and
and possibly not quickly enough to
defeat a disease if we can understand
how the body communicates with itself at
a very scientific and biologic basis
then we can learn to intervene in that
discussion that the body is having and
get it to steer a different course so
for instance if one gets a cut the
typical way that one would heal is to
create a scar ourselves in the region of
the cut would hear a number of signals
that say create a scar regenerative
medicine is all about taking many
different kinds of tools from lots of
different kinds of disciplines and
disrupting the normal way that the body
heals but allowing it to heal in perhaps
a more natural way so that the end
result is for instance a scarless
healing process where you get healing
that creates natural tissue but not scar
tissue
people actually are naturally excited by
the idea of having a disease a
debilitating disease cured so if you go
to the doctor today there are certain
words which strike fear into your heart
cancer diabetes Alzheimer's Parkinson's
these these are words that alter the
course of your wife but but there are
other words which don't you know a sore
throat some kind of infection technology
is what is being used in the past to
diminish that fear because if we can
invent new ways of treating disease we
we can resolve very tragic outcomes so I
think these things are exciting
regenerative medicine is exciting
because it really represents a rather
new paradigm in how to deliver health to
people who are challenged and and what
we're able to do with regenerative
medicine is actually cure disease rather
than treating symptoms and that just
inherently is very exciting to people
if one rejects the idea of rationing
health care to younger people and
embraces the idea of trying to deliver
healthy aging one needs tools to do that
so of course one could think about
things like organ transplant and you
talked about machines and devices the
idea of machines and devices being used
to support function but typically we
think of those kinds of health care
options as later on in the cycle of a
disease so you know we get sick we get
more sick may get even more sick and
then some incredible new technology
comes along that can help us
unfortunately it's often really
expensive to deliver and it doesn't
always work so well and there are lots
of side effects so this fascinating
balance between early diagnosis and a
set of tools that allow you to intervene
early on and delay what until then was
inevitable a very exciting so early
diagnosis and regeneration of function
represent a new way of treating disease
there is a hypothesis somewhat
controversial called the cancer stem
cell hypothesis that posits that many
cancers are caused by stem cells that
have gone wrong so when we were growing
up when I was growing up and being
taught about cancer in high school
biology classes I always got the sense
that that every cell inside a tumor was
bad and equally dangerous but it turns
out that stem cell biologists that are
focused on cancer have discovered that
actually only a small percentage of
cells inside a tumor are necessarily bad
and have the ability to go somewhere
else and create another tumor and it's
that metastasis of cancer that causes
that really wreaks havoc for cancer
patients it turns out that those cells
are probably stem cells and they're very
very similar to normal stem cells so
let's think about the implications of
that well first of all if it's true one
implication is that if we go about
trying to find drugs to treat tumors by
looking for drugs which shrink tumor
masses we may miss the important drugs
because if one in a million cells is bad
and we just find a drug that gets rid of
999999 cells and miss the one the drug
doesn't kill the one that's bad you know
we bought some time but we didn't cure
the disease so people who do
regenerative medicine are driven by the
idea of curing a disease so for cancer
stem cells what they're interested in
doing is first identifying them second
of all determining what's their role in
cancer and then lastly and perhaps most
excitingly and most importantly asking
the question how can we selectively
destroy cancer stem cells so that they
can't read havoc by moving to another
site in creating missed a thesis
this technology that's come out to the
University of Wisconsin is even even
more crazy to think about but but it
appears that it that it has real
potential and and there the issue is
let's figure out a way to send the
signal and let's ignore the eyes
completely let's send a vision signal
through the tongue now we taste with our
tongue and obviously we use it when we
eat right and we're not talking here
about trying to convert vision into
taste we're just saying that you know
what the brains pretty smart and and it
should be able to distinguish what's a
vision signal and what's a taste signal
so let's take a set of electrodes and
let's embed them into some kind of not
permanent implant but just something
that you can lie on to the time you
could think of I'm blanking on the name
of the thing but but one of the things
that holds braces in place assoc you
could put your tongue up against it and
and imagine on that chip where a whole
host of tiny electrodes that we're
receiving signals from a camera and then
you could ask the question if you know
if the patient was to lie their tongue
on that device or say it was like a
lollipop and they just put it in their
mouth would they see anything and it
turns out they do so the device is
called the brain port and you can go to
youtube and look at this extraordinary
device and they don't see like you like
you and I but but what they do is they
begin to be able to distinguish light
and for instance on a computer monitor
they could begin to distinguish
different letters from each other as the
letter was big enough so just imagine
you in terms of restoring function which
is one of the central elements of
returning to medicine in terms of
restoration of function what it would
mean for someone who had no eyes to be
able to lie that tongue on a device and
then be able to walk around a room
because all of a sudden they could
actually see
using the term in inverted commas they
could see roughly where different
objects work